general john kelly emerges to save
president from from himself Democrat
Frederico Wilson makes a complete fool
of herself and President George W Bush
is back we will talk about all of these
things I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
so this has been an extraordinarily
irritating week in news and that's
largely because of all the disrespect
shown toward gold star families I'm
pretty much every side of the aisle from
the media from Democrats from President
Trump all of it kind of gross but we'll
talk about all of those things in just
one second first I want to begin by
thanking our sponsors over at Birch gold
so right now the stock market is doing
incredibly well but there are a lot of
people who are suggesting that maybe
that's a bit of a bubble
the real estate market doing well right
now but that may to be a bubble if you
are afraid it is the very least you can
do is diversify with some precious
metals the fact is the precious metals
have never been worth nothing they've
always held a certain amount of value
and they've always held their value
pretty well right now the price of gold
has been doing well over the past
several months as well if you are
interested in getting some precious
metals and you are interested in
transferring your IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold or
silver go over to my friends at Birch
gold group right now they've a 16 page
free kit revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings and how you can
make that move from an IRA or 401k into
precious metals IRA so go over and check
it out right now birchgold.com slash Ben
that's birchgold.com slash Ben they're
the people that I trust with my precious
metals investing again they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success with thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews and
reviews and an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau go to birchgold.com
slash Ben they're the folks that you can
trust okay so yesterday let's let's set
the stage because yesterday was a pretty
incredible press conference from General
John Kelly the White House chief of
staff so we need to set the stage
because I want to show how there are
really only two innocent parties in this
whole hubbub that has now lasted the
entirety of the week over the treatment
of gold star families those two innocent
parties are general Kelly the White
House chief of staff and the Johnson
family in Florida those are the only two
innocent parties Democrat Frederica
Wilson was clearly looking to get Trump
it's pretty clear to me that she was
looking to politicize the situation and
president Trump is the one who led this
whole thing off by going out and saying
that President Obama and President Bush
had somehow done something wrong and how
they treated gold star families and they
had insufficiently called all the
members of gold
families so that's how it started okay
let's recall the back on month I think
it was Monday morning President Trump
gave a press conference in which he was
asked specifically about why he had not
reached out to all of the soldiers
families of the soldiers who were killed
in Niger on October 4th and the
president suggested that he had called
all of the soldiers or at least that
other presidents had not called all the
soldiers and he had and this caused a
bit of a firestorm and then because as I
say the media are intent on taking
everything Trump says and taking it 10
steps too far they decide it's important
to show that Trump actually is not
sympathetic to the troops himself he in
fact is cruel and inhumane to the troops
and then just coincidentally right then
President Trump calls up Myesha Johnson
who is the widow of 'la David Johnson
the sergeant who was killed in Niger
they're still open questions to be asked
if you want to know what those hoping
questions are listen to yesterday's show
but he calls her up and suddenly there's
a huge firestorm because one of the
people in the car when the call happens
is fredericka Wilson the Democrat
congresswoman from Florida
she is a colorful figure to say the
least she's the woman who wears all the
crazy hats she's the one who had
suggested that george zimmerman be put
in prison for his own protection during
the trayvon martin situation and she is
a publicity hound to say the very least
but she also is close with the johnson
family apparently apparently she'd known
them for quite a while
the david johnson had a one-point intern
for her i guess and she was in the car
when Trump made this phone call so
during the course of the phone call one
of the phrases that Trump said was
something to the effect of he knew what
he signed up for and there were two ways
to read that phrase as I suggested at
the time way one was Trump saying he
knew it he signed up for four so is it
really unexpected which is a terrible
thing to say and the other is he was a
hero and he knew what he signed up for
and he was doing what he wanted to do
when he was killed he was with his
buddies trying to defend the country
which is a very different connotation
now to be completely innocent in all of
this - to be completely to take the most
innocent view of this it is quite
possible that when you are doing a
morning phone call people can take the
same terms the wrong way right you we
all know this we go to funerals and you
don't know what to say to somebody's
family the family the person who died
it's very very difficult which is why in
Judaism we actually have a formula that
you say because we really understand
that there isn't much you can say to
comfort some
money upon the death of a family member
and so we say in Hebrew I Malcolm you
knocking that's come to suck
Shari yerushalayim heavily Shari ashlynn
so the idea is that you may be comforted
among the mourners for Zion in Jerusalem
right that's it it's a it's the same
thing we say when you hear somebody has
died in Judaism there's also a formula
for that we say Barack Diana met meaning
blessed is the true judge meaning
blessed is God the reason we do that is
not just because we think these things
are true although we do it's because
there really aren't a lot of great
things that you can say when somebody
dies and it is very easy to step into a
landmine when you're talking with
somebody and so the most innocent the
most innocent take on this situation is
that Trump said something that he didn't
mean to be offensive and the family felt
offended by it
which is possible I mean that's possible
but whatever the situation let's take
even that most innocent of scenarios the
people who are to blame for this big
controversy our first Trump for bringing
up the controversy to begin with on
Monday when second fredericka Wilson who
decides to go public and make a huge
issue and suggest that Trump doesn't
care about the families of soldiers so
yesterday so yesterday yeah John Kelly
who had been dragged into this
controversy kicking and screaming
apparently at one point he had told
Trump that President Obama did not call
him after his son's death John Kelly's a
gold star father his son was killed in
Afghanistan in 2010 he had told Trump
that Obama didn't call him after his son
died and the Trump administration
immediately ran to the microphones to
throw that information out there the
suggestion being here is some support
for the idea that Obama didn't call
everybody
John Kelly must have been angry about
that in his comments yesterday he came
out and basically what he was attempting
to do I think was restore some dignity
to this process
okay the calls between the president and
the family members those are sacred the
the death of so of servicemembers that
is sacred the politicization of these
issues is really gross and I think
that's what Kelly was trying to do with
this press conference yesterday here is
John Kelly yesterday the White House
chief of staff who took control of the
press conference and and really I think
we shifted the debate there's no perfect
way to make that phone call
when I took this job and talked to
President Trump about how to do it my
first recommendation was he not do it
because it's not the phone call that
parents family members are looking
forward to it's a nice to do in my
opinion in any event he asked previous
presidents and I said I can tell you
that President Obama who was my
commander in chief when I was on active
duty did not call my family that was not
a criticism that was just to simply say
I don't believe President Obama called
that's not a negative thing
I don't believe President Bush called in
all cases I don't believe any president
particularly when the casualty rates are
very very high that the president's call
did I believe they all right okay so you
know I think that this was his way of
basically trying to take the sting out
of the out of the allegation that he was
somehow accusing obama of some
shortcoming in this respect he then went
on and he attacked Frederick Wilson for
making this into a major issue it stuns
me that a member of Congress would have
listened in on that conversation
absolutely stuns me and I thought at
least that was sacred you know when I
was a kid growing up a lot of things
were Sager in our country and when I
listen to this woman and what she was
saying and what she was doing on TV the
only thing I could do to collect my
thoughts was to go and walk among the
finest men and women on this earth and
you can always find them because they're
in Arlington National Cemetery when over
there for an hour and a half
walked among the stones some of whom I
put there because they were doing what I
told them to do when they were killed I
mean truly somber stuff obviously and
what he's saying is is basically correct
that this is not the time before
Congress people to be coming out and
ripping the presidents of the United
States anew on for stuff that is at best
a disagreement over meaning Kelly went
further who's very upset obvious with
Frederica Wilson he feels
she was using this as a publicity stunt
in order to promote her own career and
he is not shy about saying so and a
congresswoman stood up and in the long
tradition of empty barrels making the
most noise stood up there and all of
that and talked about how she was
instrumental in getting the funding for
that building now she took care of her
constituents because she got the money
and she just called up President Obama
and on that phone call he gave the money
the twenty million dollars to build a
building she sat down and we was stunned
stunned that she'd done it even for
someone that is that empty a barrel we
were stunned
I mean so he was clearly looking gone
for Frederick Wilson now there are some
people who have pushed back on Kelley's
factual claims here they've suggested
that this building had already been
funded that fredericka Wilson didn't
claim that she had that she had received
the funding for the building that what
she had done was sponsored the name
change of the building to pay tribute to
the fallen but it doesn't change what
he's largely saying here which is Husing
that she went there and she glorified
herself for doing this thing now James
Comey was there at the time by the way
and he thanked Frederick Wilson for that
so I want to be fair to Frederica Wilson
so Kelly comes out and his basic take
care is guys this is sacred stuff
stop playing with fire now I do think
that we have to that that goes both ways
again I think the Trump is not innocent
here I think Frederico wilson clearly is
not innocent here here's Frederico
wilson yesterday upon being enforced a
mazing but she's this incompetent and
here's the colorfully beheaded Frederico
Wilson talking after being informed that
John Kelly had a had gone after her from
the White House threatening phone calls
from white nationalists and now for
harsh words from the White House you may
need to tell me that I have become so
important
just stomach-churning stuff I mean when
you're talking about whether the memory
of an American hero was disgraced
walking around calling yourself a rock
star and laughing about it is probably
not the way to do it by this morning of
course she changed her tune
now she's accusing John Kelly of being a
racist really she was on new day this
morning on CNN this is clip 14 and she
is openly accusing John Kelly of being a
racist and no you're right he didn't get
the facts new head right on that was
that empty barrels make the most noise
and he was using that he was likening
that to you basically that you're how
they got some that's a racist term to
I'm thinking about that when I we looked
it up in the dictionary because I had
never heard of an empty battle and I
don't like to be dragged into something
like that okay the idea that it's a
racist term again no no I hadn't heard
the term either but I'm pretty sure that
that was not a racist term if you had to
look it up in the dictionary
good shot it wasn't and then she
continued along these lines she said
that that Kelly had lied about her and
then he had slandered her so now we're
in a Frederick Wilson versus John Kelly
fight now what's amazing here is that
Frederica Wilson is claiming that John
Kelly is a racist and that he is a bigot
and that he is a liar I'm old enough to
remember back in 2016 when Kaiser Kahn
got up goldstar father got up at the
Democratic National Convention and
attacked President Trump and then
candidate Trump came back and attacked
Kaiser Khan's wife and there were two
weeks of the outrage over Trump's
treatment of this gold star family we're
gonna hear anything like that about
Frederico Wilson's treatment of John
Kelly he is a gold star father after all
we're gonna hear anything like that from
the media of course not here's Frederico
Wilson doing this routine I heard his
remarks and I heard him say that I
bragged that I
secured the money for the building of
the FBI building in Miramar and that's a
lie you know I feel sorry for general
Kelly
he has my sympathy for the loss of his
son but he can't just go on TV and lie
on me I was not even in Congress in 2009
when the money for the building was
secured so that's a lie
how dare he however I named the building
at the behest of director Comey with the
health of Speaker Boehner working across
party lines so he didn't tell the truth
and he needs to stop telling lies on me
okay so obviously no she's very upset as
I say the main claim that Kelly was
making is that she went to this event
and then she made it all about herself I
don't know if that's true I haven't seen
the tape but that is not the claim that
she is saying that they Kelly lied about
she's saying that Kelly lied about her
grabbing the money for the building or
something along those lines in any case
the Democrats are taking precisely the
wrong tack on all of this and I'll
explain in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at my Patriot supply so you've seen
natural disasters in a number of places
this season that you've seen them in
Texas you've seen them in Florida Eve's
in the Porto Rico we've had a bunch here
in California bunch of wildfires here in
California there are situations in which
you are going to need to survive on
whatever food is in your house for the
next couple of days at least and you're
not gonna be able to get out of the
grocery store the grocery store may be
closed and then there may be a rush on
food the government may not be able to
get to you so the very least you can do
to protect your family is ensure that
you have the one hundred and two
servings survival food kit for 99 bucks
from prepare with been calm it includes
breakfast lunches and dinners it is
shipped to your home for free call eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen that's eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen or go online
to prepare with been calm the emergency
food lasts up to 25 years in storage
they basically take it you put in her
closet forget about it and then you're
gonna be glad that you went ahead and
did this if God forbid some sort of
disaster strikes my Patriots apply
believes in self-reliance and that's why
I trust them don't wait to act eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or prepare with
Ben calm
again you know there are certain things
the government recommends you have on
hand potable water flashlights well the
fact is that you should also have some
sort of emergency food supply just in
case as I prepare with Ben's comm is for
again prepare with Ben comm 888 803 1413
get there 102 serving survival food kit
for just $99 ok so the Democrats
naturally felt the need to do the
stupidest possible thing here and so
thus they did here is Brian Fallon Brian
Fallon as a former Hillary Clinton
spokesperson and he tweeted this out
with regard to Kelly's press her
yesterday Kelly isn't just an enabler of
Trump he's a believer in him that makes
him his odious as the rest don't be
distracted by the uniform don't be
distracted by the uniform I mean as Eric
Erickson said I'm mostly distracted by
the Goldstar the fact is that he is a
gold star father is John Kelly the fact
is that a lot of Democrats are now
attacking a gold star father as I said
before if the situation were reversed
which is precisely what they're accusing
they would never stop talking about it I
mean he's not the only one who's doing
this routine joy Reid tweeted a bunch of
times last night lawrence O'Donnell the
execrable lawrence O'Donnell on MSNBC he
did an entire routine about how John
Kelly was actually a racist based on the
fact that John Kelly grew up in a
segregated area or a highly racially
divided area I guess in New England
somewhere but here's joy joy reads
tweets is 17 so joy Reid of MSNBC she
makes the same sorts of claims Brian
Fallon Wow lawrence O'Donnell scorched
general Kelly tonight including calling
out his segregated Boston upbringing and
dehumanization of a black woman Wow Wow
Wow
lawrence noted the general kelly didn't
even give representative wilson the
dignity of using her name kelly grew up
in segregated Boston in an Irish
Catholic neighborhood where women were
bullied not honored and blacks scorned
and rejected and then she she continued
along these lines again
what like really didn't what for John
Kelly being offended by Frederica Wilson
because you say that he grew up in an
area like Boston so everyone from Boston
now cannot speak out when Frederica
Wilson says something X purple about
about President Trump with regard to the
troops we can't see I know now one thing
I think is important to do here is
actually play a phone call from
President Trump to a military Widow and
I want to show you that I think this is
bad
because the the line here has been the
President Trump is not sympathetic
enough to military families right that's
how this whole controversy blew up even
bigger than it was when after Trump got
it started the Washington Post has
gotten hold of President Trump calling a
Goldstar widow and and here's what the
phone calls sounded like does this sound
like somebody who is unsympathetic to
gold star families Thank You president
those words are very kind that he was an
amazing man an amazing husband and
amazing soldier and I couldn't be more
proud of my husband that I am right now
so hard to be honest with you it's
wonderful
yes he's just the all-around guy and um
I'm glad that she got to get to know a
little bit goes on like this remember
every minutes know what's funny about
this call is that at some point in here
she explains that her son is playing
quarterback for the Missouri football
team and apparently got in on an
academic scholarship and Trump jokingly
says something like wow are you kids
that talented or some less talented than
others and she laughs and then she says
no all my kids are really talented the
press right over at the Washington Post
one of the reporters that the Washington
Post takes that one line out of context
in which Trump says you know are all
your kids talented or just that one and
uses it as sort of a club like Oh
Trump's asking her to rank her kids in
order of preference
she laughs okay everyone knows that he's
Kuantan he's kind of joking here but but
again you're listening to the tone from
President Trump does this sound like
somebody who's unsympathetic again I
don't think I own the Obama was
unsympathetic to the troops I think he
lied about what happened in Benghazi but
I don't think he was unsympathetic to
the troops I don't think is an
unsympathetic
gold star families I don't think Bush
was unsympathetic to gold star families
I don't think Clinton was unsympathetic
to gold star families I don't think
Trump is unsympathetic to gold star
families and the idea that we're now
gonna play this game where everybody is
unsympathetic to gold star families
because it's the ultimate insult that
you can leverage against someone I think
is truly pretty gross now Trump himself
should keep silent he is not he tweeted
out about congresswoman Wilson say he
wants to get in a slap fight with her he
tweeted the fake news is going crazy
with wacky congresswoman Wilson who was
secretly on a very personal call and
gave a total lie on content this is one
thing that John Kelly said I just didn't
get at one point he said you know
fredericka wilson shouldn't have even
been listening in on that call well I
mean you can see that there are lots of
people listening in on these calls right
even in the in the phone call we just
showed from the Washington Post you can
see there's a military attache there
John Kelly said openly that he was
listening in on that exact same phone
call so if the Johnson family wanted
Wilson there they have every right to
have Wilson there if they want the
problem with Wilson is that she decided
to go out and blab to the press about it
and try and turn it into some sort of
politicized issue that is the problem
with what she did here not that she was
present in any case should president
from stop this yes should Frederica
Wilson stop this yes okay if this stuff
is to remain sacred you know I've had
members of my extended family die right
of both my grandfather's passed away a
while ago my aunt passed away and in any
case where somebody who is close to you
in any way dies the tendency is to go
very silent the tendency is to be very
quiet it's why again in Judaism I think
Judaism actually does mourning exactly
right I think Judaism is is a religion
that does mourning better than any other
religion we actually take a week off of
work
it's called sitting Shiva you're not
allowed to leave the house you basically
you sit on a low stool to signify your
mourning people come and visit you
people bring meals they actually perform
the the prayer services in the morning
in your house they actually bring Torah
over and and like an entire group of men
come over to to pray with you and the
idea here is that it's supposed to be
both private and communal and what's
happened here is precisely the opposite
it's public and individual it's not
communal and it's not private and that
is I think the opposite of what should
happen here thanks to John Kelly for
attempting to restore some dignity to
this process I mean I
that's too much to ask thanks also to
the family I will say Myesha Johnson has
been incredibly classy throughout this
this is the the widow of the of the
sergeant who was slain in Niger
she's been totally silent about that she
hasn't said anything and she's not
obligated to say anything so good for
her and and everyone else I think has
been garbage
I think the media's been awful I think
Trump has been awful I think Frederico
Wilson has been awful I think there's
just a generalized lack of class that
now has extended to this most sacred of
spaces okay so in other news President
Bush gave a speech yesterday and I want
to go through this speech I think it's
actually important to go through this
speech for a couple of reasons one I
think the speech itself is quite good
second I'm seeing a lot of blowback from
conservatives who are saying well you
know he's just being mean to Trump it's
directed against Trump and he's
impugning my honor itto people I like
people people who I work with who are
saying this I want to go through Bush's
speech because I think what Bush's
speech was was just a reiteration of
classical conservatism if you don't like
the reiteration of classical
conservatism if you think that somehow
insulting to your points of view then I
think that you are you ought to look at
your own points of view more closely and
if you're on the left and you think the
bush was only slapping Trump at this in
the speech he wasn't ok Bush was not
just slapping Trump in this speech we'll
go through the speech and I will show
you he slaps left just as much as he
slaps the the nationalist populist right
both of which I think are deserving of
slaps it doesn't matter he never makes
explicit reference to President Trump it
doesn't matter the media have been doing
this pathetic routine where it's Bush
slams trumpism hey Bush also slammed
leftism but you ignored that part didn't
you you pretended that never happened
you pretended this isn't the same sort
of stuff that Bush has been saying his
entire career where I've been saying my
entire career or traditional
conservatives Reagan conservatives have
been saying their entire career you
pretended that this was a going out of
his way to slap Trump moment because he
had to be become part of the resistance
that's not what this was at all this was
Bush reiterating basic conservative
principles and somehow this is now
offensive and by the way I have to say
the media over the last over the last
week or so over the last few months
they've been doing this uh Turley
pathetic routine Nancy Pelosi came out
two days ago and she said I sort of wish
that Romney were president
you go to hell lady you're the one who
was suggesting that Romney was a brutal
sexist in 2012 I'm hearing Bill say all
up being a bush that was a that was a
classy guy you called Bush Hitler you
suggested he was behind 9/11 you can all
go to hell it was your slander of good
men like George W Bush and Mitt Romney
that led the Republicans to ignore
character quality in in nominating
President Trump because they figured at
least if you're gonna call us a bunch of
jackasses anyway we're gonna call us a
bunch of racist sexist big at home of
folks who hate the poor and secretly
want to perpetrate terrorist attacks
then we'll just nominate whoever is the
guy who hits the hardest regardless as
to whether he's a good guy or not so the
left has a lot to answer for here anyway
here is someone Bush's speech I thought
this was a great speech and I really
want to go through it at length because
I think that it speaks to a a mode of
conservatism that unfortunately has been
lost in in the modern era wouldn't when
conservatism is apparently or at least
right-wing thought is more about the
attitude than it is about the thought so
here is President Bush he starts off by
saying that you know there was a
bipartisan consensus that America's
freedom was tied to her security and all
of those were tied to our fundamental
values for more than seventy years the
presidents of both parties believe that
American Security and Prosperity were
directly tied to the success of freedom
in the world they knew that the success
depended in large part on US leadership
the mission came naturally because it
expressed the DNA of American idealism
okay so there is he he set a couple of
lines in the speech I thought there's a
good line he said a couple of lines in
the speech I disagreed with and this is
where I think Bush strays from
traditional conservatism which looks at
man is inherently sinful or at least of
divided mind Bush had this this kind of
Wilsonian notion that there was a
yearning in the human heart for freedom
I don't think that's right I think the
value of freedom does not lie in our
desire for it the value for the value of
freedom lies in the capacity of freedom
to allow us to choose to be more
virtuous human beings a free will is an
inherent part of being human whatever
maximizes our
to exercise that freewill without
invading the rights of others that's
what we should be striving for that's
why freedom is good not because lots of
people like it lots of people like ice
cream doesn't mean if you eat only ice
cream you'll be fine
the fact is Norma swaths enormous wads
of humanity do not believe in basic
freedom so this is where I disagree with
Bush this is my sole point really in
this speech of disagreement with
President Bush here's what he had to say
we know deep down that repression is not
the wave of the future
we know that the desire for freedom is
not confined to our own by any culture
it is the inborn hope of our humanity I
do not think this is true I think this
is a myth that the desire for freedom is
not confined to any culture or owned by
any culture Western civilization has for
a long time had a pretty solid monopoly
on what we would now call freedom yeah
this is an outgrowth of judeo-christian
civilization okay it did not exist in
the East it did not exist it does not
exist now in Islamic countries now the
idea that it's not held in by any
culture is not true culture does have a
lot to do the freedom there are cultures
of freedom and cultures of non freedom
and thankfully freedom has spread to
other cultures so maybe it can be
grafted onto other cultures but the idea
that it wasn't an outgrowth of a
particular culture or that cultures are
all equal in their desire for freedom or
that people are all equal in their
desire for freedom I don't think that's
true people are equal in their in their
value before God we are not all equal in
our desire for freedom that hole in
Bush's philosophy is large enough to
drive a truck through and that's what
allowed President Trump to act as the
realist answer to Bush ISM and President
Obama to pretend that he was a realist
in in sort of contravention of these
freedom ideals but the rest of Bush's
speech is a basic statement of
traditional conservatism and a bunch of
people on the right were mad and a bunch
of people on the left where it were
gleeful because they thought that Bush
was attacking Trump here is is what
President Bush had to say the American
dream of upward mobility seems out of
reach for some who feel left behind in a
changing economy discontent deepened and
sharpened partisan conflicts bigotry
seems emboldened our politics seems more
vulnerable to conspiracy theories and
outright fabrication so people took this
as a as a critique of Trump specifically
but it's not just a critique of Trump
it's a critique also of the resistance
mentality it says the Russians stole the
election it's a critique of the idea
that that bigotry only exists on one
side as Bush made clear later in the
speech what he's saying here is correct
right there is a discontent with our
institutions and it has led to a
partisanship that is really quite
vicious and that vicious partisanship is
coming from a lack of meaning which is
something that I talked about a
University of Tennessee
he continues here and he says that one
of the big problems here is that because
of that discontent support for some of
the basic ideas that found in the
country have waned there are some signs
that the intensity of support for
democracy itself is waned especially
among the young who never experienced
the galvanizing moral clarity of the
Cold War or never focused on the ruin of
entire nations by socialists central
planning right so what he's saying there
this is what the left ignores right
that's a pretty harsh attack on the left
you guys don't remember the Cold War you
don't remember all the evil communist
nations attempting to kill us you
remember any of this stuff like really
and maybe you ought to remember that
socialised central planning has always
been a giant fail right they don't
they're not willing to pay attention to
any of those things so the reason I'm
pointing all this out is because the
caricature of Bush's speech is that Bush
was just out there attacking Trump that
is not true and I'll play a little bit
more of that speech but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsor is over at
MVM T so MVM T watches fantastic watches
here is my MVM T watch I wear it every
day I wore before Congress it is a great
watch I bought one for my wife as well
everyone around the office is getting
MVM T watches my wife gets complimented
on her watch all the time because they
are really nice looking they're
minimalist in design which makes them
look really classy and they are
minimalist in price they started just 95
bucks at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks for these
kinds of watches they're classic design
quality construction I mean I've really
bang the crap out of this watch and it
still looks great I mean like I've
really knocked the bejesus out of this
thing I have little kids and so my son
really likes holding it and throwing it
on the floor for some odd reason and it
just stands up fantastic it looks the
same as the day that I bought it it's
just terrific they'd sold over a million
watches in over 160 countries and you
can get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to MBM t.com
slash shapiro
that's MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro go
check it out
join the movement it's really great
movement watches MBM t.com and use that
slash up here you get 15% off today I
couldn't recommend the watch more highly
okay so just to finish up President
Bush's speech again I think it's
ridiculous that the Wright was attacking
him on this all of this is self-evident
all of this is basic conservatism the
fact that we think that you
w bush's brand of being a mensch i mean
this is just a mensch ii speech okay men
is yiddish for being a man it means like
being a gentleman bush whatever i think
of his policy and i disagreed with him
on a number on an innumerable number of
things right i disagreed with him on
campaign finance reform i disagreed with
him on medicare part d i disagree with
him on No Child Left Behind i disagreed
with him on immigration reform i
disagreed with him on the tarp bailouts
i disagreed with him on a huge bevy of
issues but george w bush was a classy
guy and his philosophy his philosophy
was basically traditional conservatism
and much more reflective of traditional
conservatism than the so-called
brand-new populist nationalism that
really is not an ideology it's more just
an attitude that were angry at stuff so
here is here is bush going on and
talking about our discourse beings
granted again people are taking this as
merely a referendum on trump that is
ignoring the discourse that they need
the destruction of our discourse by the
left as well we've seen our discourse
degraded by casual cruelty at times it
could seem like the forces pulling us
apart are stronger than the forces
binding us together argument turns to
easily into animosity disagreement
escalates into dehumanization too often
we judge other groups by their worst
examples while judging ourselves by our
best intentions for getting the image of
god we should see in each other what
he's saying right here again this is
basic conservative thought and he
critiqued nativism and isolationism and
then he finished this is the second last
clip of Bush and his H he finished by
talking about our identity as a nation
suggesting that it's all about these
ideals these are the ideals that both
the the alt-right
and the populist nationalist on the one
hand and the socialist Democrat left
ignore right this idea that he's about
to say is Americanism in a nutshell this
is why I like the speech this is classy
our identity as a nation unlike many
other nations is not determined by
geography or ethnicity by soil or blood
being an American involves the embrace
of high ideals and civic responsibility
we become the heirs of Thomas Jefferson
by accepting the ideal of human dignity
found in the Declaration of Independence
we become the heirs of James Madison by
understanding the genius and values of
the US Constitution we become the heirs
of Martin Luther King jr. by recognizing
one another not by the color of their
skin but by the content of their
character this means that people of
every race religion ethnicity can be
fully and equally American it means that
bigotry or white supremacy in any form
is blasphemy against the American creed
and it means the very identity of our
nation depends on the passing of civic
ideals to the next generation how can
you be critical of that how if you're on
the right and you feel like this speech
was a critique of Trump maybe it's
because Trump deserves to be critiqued
and if you're on the left and you feel
like this is a critique of Trump
maybe it's because you're not looking
deep enough into your own heart to
realize this was also a critique of you
okay George W Bush a speech I thought
yesterday was quite grand and he you
know I don't miss a lot of his policies
but I miss him as a man you know he was
a good man and I miss I miss having a
good man in the office of the White
House I think it's been a long time
since we've had a good man just a a
gentleman who's not interested in
dividing the country along racial lines
for political purposes it's been a long
time not just Trump but also Obama it's
been a long time since we've had a
person who actually felt that that
American unity was was necessary and
positive in the White House said you
know it's it's it's sad the way our
country has spun out of control since
2007 over the last decade or so okay so
I I do have some stuff that I like and
some stuff that I hate but for that
you're gonna have an in the mail bag if
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire calm right now and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can get daily wire
calm that gets you access to the rest of
the show live on video
it gets you access to the rest of Andrew
Klavan show and Michael Moses show live
on video it also means you get to see
our website banner ad free you also are
going to be able to get where the
Shapiro story is coming by the way folks
I haven't said in a while it is coming I
know this for a fact it is long delayed
but it will not be further denied
we'll come and there will be benefits
for members as well we will have to well
we'll make sure that you have promo
codes and all the rest I'm also from for
$99 a year you can get an annual
subscription over at daily wire.com and
that comes along with this the most
magnificent of all leftist to tears hot
or cold tumblers it carries all of your
beverages in just the condition you
would wish them to be carried is it's
quite fun so make sure that you get that
as well or if you just want to listen
later for free go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and make sure that you get a
and make sure that you leave us a review
and subscribe we always do appreciate it
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so a couple of things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like so on the plane
yesterday I never have a chance to watch
movies because I'm busy all the time and
I have children um but I was able to
watch The Foundry yesterday on the plane
the founder is starring Michael Keaton
it's about Ray Kroc who was the who was
sort of the founder that's the irony of
the title is that his name isn't
McDonald's right right it was the
McDonald's brothers who actually founded
McDonald's and then Ray Kroc came in and
turned it into a national chain and
here's a little bit of the preview I
know what you're thinking how the heck
does a fifty two-year-old over-the-hill
milkshake machine salesman build a fast
food Empire with 1,600 restaurants and
an annual revenue of seven hundred
million dollars one word persistence Wow
a lot interest mixers joy anyone
particularly McDonald's there for a
little tour we wanted something
different and that's when my brother
here comes up with one of us brilliant
ideas orders ready in 30 seconds not 30
minutes unique original there's nothing
like this it's exactly what its
revolutionary what is that the golden
arches it's a way to make the place to
stand out huh there should be McDonald's
everywhere franchise the damn thing mr.
crudd franchise franchise franchise
McDonald's can be the new American
Church and I ain't just open on Sundays
boys how can we be almost on a Capitol
did you mortgage our home we could lose
everything
I want Ari negotiate my lousy deal their
camp Gander won't ray what no what you
ought to be doing is owning the land
upon which that burger is cooked you're
not in the burger business you're in the
real estate business
okay so what's envious doesn't really
show at least in the beginning of the
preview that the story is really the
story of Ray Kroc being a jerk right
that it starts off and he's just an
idealistic guy who wants to make
something of himself and he's kind of a
he's kind of a showboat and a Salesman
and as the movie goes on you see that he
becomes more of a sleazebag that he
divorces his wife I mean he's in this is
all history so it's not really spoiler
alert time and that the brother is the
McDonald brothers hands up trying to cut
them out of their own business and all
the rest of it and that the take of the
movie is supposed to be that American
capitalism this consumerist capitalism
screws the little guy really screws the
little guy I had a couple of problems
with this particular tank so I thought
the movie is really well done I had a
couple of problems with this particular
tank so the the whole movie is built
around the rivalry between Ray Kroc who
is a Salesman who comes to McDonald's
brothers and says we are going to turn
this into a a franchise and the
McDonald's brothers who are trying to
maintain quality and who don't want to
and who don't want to compromise quality
in favor of money and all the rest of it
and in the movie to make a point of
saying McDonald's brothers were also
Republicans but they kind of jab
Ronald Reagan near the end because
Michael because Michael Keaton's
character Ray Kroc is speaking at an
event for Ronald Reagan that sort of
close to the movie um that here is my
problem my problem is twofold one Ray
Kroc is portrayed as the villain of the
film and he is but Ray Kroc civility and
these quote unquote villainy of
capitalism results in legitimately tens
of thousands of people becoming
inordinately wealthier right people who
actually franchise this thing if the
McDonald's brothers had just been left
to their own devices as the movie shows
there had been one McDonald's franchise
in San Bernardino McDonald's would not
have been a national chain it would've
been like four four stores and that
would've been it and Ray Kroc did take
that and build it into a multi national
enormous corporation doing 700 million
dollars worth of business every year
right and that made a lot of people
wealthier and made food a lot more
available and a lot cheaper and you may
not like the fast food but that's none
of your business because it's a free
country okay so that's number one number
two there's this idea that Ray Kroc
clearly is screwing the brothers now Ray
Kroc I don't know that much about him as
a business person but in the film at
least just to take their narrative Ray
Kroc ends up dropping a million dollars
into the into the pockets of of each
brother he's the one again who really
takes their French their little store
and turns it into a national franchise
he is the driving force behind making
McDonald's an actual thing and you know
it's pretty clear that he's cutthroat
they they try to make him out to be
cutthroat the brothers end up with
making over a million dollars each one
of the weird things about the film and
one of the weird claims the brothers
later made is they claimed that they had
a handshake deal with Ray Kroc that he
was gonna provide them one percent of
all future profits future net profits
from McDonald's and it was a handshake
deal I have a problem with this just
because they signed the contracts with
him and one of the key components of the
of the beginning of the movie is that
they sign a contract with with Ray Kroc
that he continues to break and they are
very strict about enforcing that
contract the idea that they would have
done a handshake deal with Ray Kroc over
1 percent of the future profits of a
company I find that a little bit hard to
believe now again I don't know enough to
know if that's if that's accurate or not
but if that's the claim then that's
that's just foolish business I mean this
is why we have lawyers and clearly
didn't even trust Kroc at that point in
any case was Ray Kroc a jerk I don't
know much about him in a move
he certainly is does capitalism make
people better
no capitalism can give them the
opportunity to be worse people as they
make it out for Ray Kroc here at the
same time capitalism can also make a lot
of people much wealthier who are good
people and who are trying to to to do
something worthwhile with their lives I
mean one of the things that the movie
does show is a bunch of people who are
sort of salt-of-the-earth types who are
franchising because they're good at
keeping their stores clean and they're
doing what they need to do in order to
make the store successful so it's a
really interesting film I just wouldn't
swallow wholesale the anti-capitalist
narrative of the film because I don't
think it's it's accurate or even
reflective of the material in the film
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate okay so let's begin with Richard
Spencer at University of Florida so
Richard Spencer is a garbage human and
Richard Spencer is he's the leader of
this white supremacist movement he says
he's not a white supremacist because
everyone should have their own
ethnocentric country but White's created
civilization it's a dumb argument
White's did not create civilization
Westerners created civilization and
Western culture created civilization not
every white created Western civilization
and not people from and people from
other cultures or other ethnicities they
are capable of assimilating into that
civilization it's just the fact that
matters I've said before now people who
were considered barbarians at one time
are now considered stalwarts and the
white supremacists in the white
supremacist notion right the Irish the
Germans the Italians right these are now
considered stalwarts in the white
supremacist pantheon
well white supremacist back in 89 you
thought all these groups were gross and
they thought Jews were gross too and a
lot of them still do so no so Richard
Spencer was speaking at University of
Florida now let me give a hint to people
on the left if you really think that
Richard Spencer is the most dangerous
man alive if you really think that he's
egregious God's I'd protest outside his
speech and then leave the crowd
completely empty nothing would be as
damaging to Richard Spencer as going to
University of Florida and him being in
an auditorium by himself twiddling his
thumbs here instead is some tape of what
actually happened at University of
Florida and Spencer is going to use this
to say that he was basically silenced
and shut down and he's a victim in the
free speech Wars
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why your
more
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
okay so there's Richard Spencer doing
his routine I spoke in University of
Florida I don't think it was in the same
auditorium I spoken in University of
Florida a few months ago and it went
great it was it was easy there are a
couple protesters outside nothing like
this why because I'm not Richard Spencer
clearly but also I want you to look at
that auditorium can you run it back a
little bit there's there's part where it
sort of Scrolls it screens through the
audience and you can see that there's a
gap of seats and then there's like two
rows of white guys in white shirts so
you'll see in just a second who's really
close to the top so what you're gonna
see here is they're the gap right gap of
empty seats lots of empty seats and then
you'll see that right in front there's a
group of white guys who are standing and
clapping right a group of white guys in
button-up white shirts who are standing
and clapping and when you see this what
you'll notice is that these are the only
Richard Spencer fans in the entire place
right there that's it right it's like
twelve guys maybe twenty guys they're
writing a 500-person theater minimum and
they're like 20 guys there imagine if
the protestors had been smart enough to
just stay outside and this entire thing
happened and there were like 15 guys
there how humiliating that would be for
Richard Spencer Richard Spencer operates
off your ire Richard Spencer operates
off your anger I don't feel that that's
what I'm here to do by the way when I
speak on campuses I say things I think
are true the fact that they piss people
off is always kind of a shock to me but
the fact is that you're giving in
Spencer what he wants don't be stupid
don't give him what he wants go protest
outside leave the auditorium absolutely
empty demonstrate that like he has seven
fans which is the reality okay other
things that I hate will do one more
thing that I hate al sharpton he I don't
even know why in the world you would
consider al Sharpton any sort of source
for anything he is now going out there
saying that President Trump is the
polarizer in chief this is a guy who as
I've said before was involved in helping
incite riots in Crown Heights in 1991
that ended with the murder of Yankel
Rosenbaum an Orthodox Jew he was
involved in in inciting violence at
Freddie's fashion Mart there a guy who
was a fan of his set a fire and it
killed eight people he he is routinely
raised baited he lied about to monobrow
lee openly he's up
piece of absolute filth al sharpton I
mean he's just a garbage person and and
yet he's being trotted out as somebody
to talk about the nature of forms
polarization but he is not just Donald
Trump in New York polarizing people he's
the President of the United States and
for the President to imply that falesha
defy the rights of citizens under arrest
for the president to throw out police
reforms that the Justice Department
investigated and found necessary it
warrants us to come out and speak loudly
and clearly that he has become the
polarizer in chief in this country he's
so polarizing he's so polarizing he may
be polarizing but um al Sharpton is not
the guy you want to try out to talk
about that okay time for a few mailbag
questions if you are a subscriber now is
the time to send in your live mailbag
questions as well so congratulations to
you Kevin says hey Ben I was wondering
why you think the LGBT community
especially the gay community has
increased over the years I've been
wondering this for a while now thanks
I'm a big fan have a good day
so I have not seen so if you mean
sympathy then I think that's largely
because of media attention if you want
to say the number of people who are
actually gay or bisexual or transit
increased there is evidence to this to
this fact the reason is because I do
think that sexual behavior is malleable
I think sexual desire is somewhat
malleable I don't think it's entirely
malleable I think it has a genetic
component and an environmental component
I think when you say to people that
whatever floats your boat is what floats
your boat people are more apt to try
things right just as when you say that
single motherhood is no longer to be
morally abhorred you get more single
motherhood when you say that
homosexuality or bisexuality is on an
equal moral plane with heterosexuality
you're likely to get more of that sexual
activity people experiment with sex
people are tempted by the forbidden and
so you get more people identifying with
these things and you see these numbers
going up dramatically in places like
Britain guys saying they're not willing
to experiment with other guys etc so I
think a lot of it has to do with media
attention and changing social mores I
don't think that that's necessarily a
good thing I think that people should
make decisions in their sex life based
on what is best for their what is best
for their happiness and I think that
promiscuity is generally not best for
happiness I think that heterosexual
marriage is generally the best for
people's happiness but not for everyone
obviously Cristal says I love you
Cristal I don't know who you are but my
wife I'm sure would not mind if I say I
love you too not knowing who you are and
hoping that you're not a horrible person
Ben says hey Ben I know quite a few
liberals who've stopped being Christians
because of the overwhelming support of
Trump by evangelical Christians what
does this say about today's society and
the future of religion in the country
will the government be our deity in 100
years thanks well first of all if they
were liberals and they were Christians
then they have some inherent
contradictions in the first place
because Christianity does not tend
toward liberalism on either the economic
spectrum or on the social spectrum for
certain on the religious freedom
spectrum leftism and and christianity
are pretty much incompatible as well if
you are this is one of my key complaints
about people who don't understand
religion if what turns you off to
religion is the adherence of religion
then you're not really turned off by
religion you're turned off by people
people suck okay people sin the entire
basis of Christianity is that people are
born into original sin Judaism doesn't
believe that people are born into
original sin but it does believe that we
have a yeats our Hara right an evil
desire an evil inclination and eh our
hatov and a good inclination and they're
constantly fighting it out if you
believe that there are people who you
disagree with on politics you did the
wrong thing because of their Christian
viewpoint and so you leave Christianity
maybe it's because you weren't a very
good Christian to begin with maybe you
should instead try and convince them and
so many Christians I know who or who
didn't vote for Trump do that they were
wrong to support Trump and if they
support Trump and they're a Christian
maybe they have good reason to do so hey
Dylan says what do you think of the
efforts in the medical medical community
to change medical eponyms named after
alleged Nazis seems similar to the
Confederate statue issue so I don't know
enough about which exact medical eponyms
would be would be attributable to Nazis
I am not in favor of wiping away things
that are accomplished
I don't like wiping away the history of
things and in whitewashing the history
of things I'm generally not a big fan of
that so as I've said about Confederate
statutes I agree with condi rice that
they should remain up and we should
every time we walk past a Confederate
statue we should remind people that the
Confederates were on the wrong side of
this argument and why and I feel the
same way about a lot of the medical
medical advances that were that were
taken under under the Nazis I think it's
important to recognize that so that we
ourselves recognize the balance between
mistreatment of human beings and medical
research because it's where we're too
apt to think that either history is
clean or that we can have it all today
that there's no conflict between say
human rights and science there very
clearly is when it comes to things like
fetal stem cells right this is a serious
issue okay Murray says what do you think
about cultural appropriation of someone
that is not Jewish wears a yarmulke as a
fashion statement is that offensive to
you as a Jewish person well first of all
if everyone started wearing a yarmulke
would make me a lot happier and then I
wouldn't stand out quite as much I think
that'd be hilarious but as far as them
wearing yarmulkes is a fashion statement
would be a weird fashion statement and I
don't really see religious icons per se
being used I think you can diminish the
value of a religious icon I'm not sure
you can diminish the value of a cultural
icon I do think there's a difference
between the two so if you were to wear a
yarmulke around outside well that has
holy meaning to me and you're sort of
defacing the holy meaning if you say as
a lot of people say well hoop earrings
are somehow a a cultural appropriation
no they're just a nice thing that you
wear and people like how it looks they
don't really have any holy meaning if
they did that that's sort of a different
story
Aaron says what are your thoughts on the
great gatsby well-written overrated
those are my thoughts on the great
gatsby f scott Fitzgerald is a beautiful
writer his word choice is phenomenal and
he writes about some of the most boring
people who ever lived his characters I'm
just not a huge Fitzgerald man I just
read Fitzgerald book recently recently
I'm trying number which one it was his
Tender is the night I just read Tender
is the night maybe four months ago and
it is not a good book
I know people praised that this whole
era of literature that people really
praised to the skies the only one from
that era of literature who I really can
stand is Hemingway I am NOT a huge f
scott Fitzgerald fan even though I think
his writing is quite beautiful Bradon
says should elected representatives vote
for what their constituents want when it
conflicts with their faith so this is a
big debate between sort of Berkey and
philosophy and and Ted Montesquieu
philosophy maybe Burkean philosophy is
you elect me to exercise my own
independent judgment this is what the
founders thought too they thought that
the purpose
Republic rather than a democracy is that
it's not my job to enforce what you want
me to do as my constituent it is my job
to do what you elected me to do which is
exercise my own independent judgment
this is why the character of the people
we elect matters this is why we don't
just vote directly on issues so no I
don't think it's wrong for you to buck
your constituents if you think they're
wrong you just may feel at the ballot
box next time Jeffs has been I know many
young people that say they are
conservative and talk as if they are but
they do not act like they are in some
cases they have no work ethic or very
little my concern is one day that will
grow up and have to actually work and
they won't know how to so my question is
do you see this with young people and if
you do what should be done I'm not
saying it's every young person but I've
noticed the shift or disappearance of
work ethic since I was younger I'm only
36 so yes Jeff I tend to agree that
there are a lot of people across the
board who claim they're conservative or
have conservative values and they don't
work and they blame circumstance the key
conserved event when people ask me why I
grew up conservative it wasn't that my
parents grew up talking about George
Bush Senior and Bill Clinton to me when
I was a kid it's that they had one
fundamental value work hard and there
will be consequences don't work hard and
there will be consequences actions have
consequences if you believe that then
root you're a conservative if you don't
believe that it route you're not Marx
says God Emperor Shapiro I'm relatively
new to the Bible what books would you
recommend I read first well honestly I
would recommend that you start by just
reading the Bible I mean I think that
you can actually just it was meant to be
read and it was meant to be understood
so I think that you should just read the
Bible itself first and then there are
specific books by CS Lewis that I think
are quite good from a Christian
perspective on the Bible there are some
books from the Jewish perspective I
think Jenna Dennis Prager actually has
quite as some good books on sort of
Jewish philosophy it depends elie wiesel
has a couple of books that are eminently
readable and really terrific there's one
called messengers of God that's really
good about the figures in Genesis that
is really fascinating and to be honest
with you I have been writing over the
past year and a half a compendium of
thoughts on the Bible and I think that
will probably bring it out sometime next
year so if you can wait for that then
then you can have some of my thoughts
you know I do the Bible thoughts every
Wednesday you can have that in more
fleshed-out form at least for the Old
Testament the five books of Moses I
get that probably next year jensine says
hey Ben my sisters keep talking about
adopting without getting married even
though I've told them that's unwise
financially and mentally for the child
they're tart by saying is a better
friend to be an orphan forever then I'm
not sure about this if marriage is out
of the question is it better to not
adopt the child and leave them be raised
an orphan or adopt as a single parent
thanks Papa blessed jensine okay so Jen
seen my view is that it is not typically
about a choice between an orphanage and
adoption your sisters are probably
talking about adopting newborns and so
what you're talking about is them
competing with a married family that's
usually what we're talking about here
the biggest problem that we have in the
adoption system is that there are too
many barriers between families that want
to adopt and kids who need to be adopted
that is the biggest problem the adoption
system I do not think that they should
treat it as listen are there gradations
of morality of course meaning that the
worst outcome is to grow up in an
orphanage the second worst outcome is to
grow up in a home with a single mom who
adopted you and the best outcome is for
you to grow up in a home with two
parents I think that if you're going to
adopt an unadoptable child who's never
been adopted by anybody else and is
stuck in the system I think it's
perfectly fair to say that I think if
you're talking about adopting a newborn
and you're up against a couple then
you're doing the wrong thing Brendan
says hey Ben what's your opinion on
Yankees fans can we all come an
agreement in two together in agreement
that they are the absolute worst people
on earth I am tempted to say yes I know
a lot of Yankees fans who are a lot of
quite wonderful people but you don't get
to complain about life if you're a
Yankees fan
you just don't okay shut up your life is
great
okay I've lived my entire life and watch
my White Sox win one championship and
suck the entire rest of my life okay
that and that is true of every other
team you guys win champion
you don't want to championship for seven
years like oh my kids never seen them
win a chance
right like I always do back by the time
the White Sox won a championship in 2005
I was already 19 years old well I was 21
years old rather I was 21 years old and
my father by that time was 49 okay so
like and my grandfather never saw it so
you shut it you just shut it okay oh
poor you
you didn't hey you do win a championship
for four or five years and now you have
the
player in the majors Aaron judge and you
have Gary Sanchez and you have a crappy
pitching staff that suddenly has decided
to pitch like they're great you go away
okay Rafael says hey man I've been
wondering if you have any methods for
studying whenever you want to learn a
subject or if you simply read about and
end up absorbing it if you do anything
specific could you share so Rafael um I
read so much that I tend to just sort of
let it wash over me and then I have a
really good memory well I don't
necessarily have a great memory for
every fact in a book but I have a good
memory for where a fact is in a book so
if I have to answer a question I know
which book to look for and where to look
it up and that's helpful and then when I
write about things I tend to remember
them very well so I think a good study
method is to write down things that you
think are important from the book by
hand there's a good way of getting in
your head Alexander says is it truly
possible to have a complete separation
between church religion and state when
objective values of morality are largely
religiously oriented for example can our
government actually be separated from
religion when its structure and powers
are based in judeo-christian values of
ethics and governance so the answer of
course is no there is no idea of
separation between church and state this
comes from a letter from Thomas
Jefferson
the idea is you cannot establish a
religion that means you cannot establish
religious practice and force me to go to
a particular church it does not mean
that I cannot vote based on values that
I derive from judeo-christian sources
Stephanie says hey Ben I think the way
you talk about your wife and children is
very inspiring my husband and I have
been married for nearly seven years at
first he wanted kids and I didn't then I
didn't he didn't now we're both in limbo
how do you know if and when you are
ready to have children honestly what is
the point of it all so first of all I
don't think there's really a point to
marriage if you don't want to have kids
then that that's a little bit of an
overstatement there's a point to
marriage and then it would be
companionship but that can be achieved
without marriage I think marriage the
point of marriage itself the institution
is for you to have kids and your kids to
be guaranteed a stable home in it how do
you know if and what do you and when
you're ready to have children I don't
think anyone's ever completely ready to
have kids I mean it's not a rat it's not
a fully rational decision to bring
someone into life who's going to be
reliant on you for the rest of your days
and who is going to suck money out of
your wallet and be an emotional drain
but I mean let's just be real about this
but it's also the most beautiful thing
in life so you know the most beautiful
thing in life is is when I go to put my
children to bed and
not because they're going to sleep but
because there's just nothing better than
holding your child and singing to them
while they're going to sleep it's just
it's the greatest thing that anyone that
God ever created and you're missing out
if you don't do this also the fact that
you and the person you love gets it
create you and your husband get to
create a human being that is part of
both of you is an unbelievable thing
it's an unbelievable gift from God and
your husband should love you enough to
want to have a child with you that is
part you and you should love your
husband enough to want to have a child
that is part of him and that's the
that's the beauty of having children as
far as financially just make sure that
you are financially responsible and that
you are you're not making decisions that
you know necessitate that your child
live in poverty but you're never gonna
be fully financially ready to have kids
because you can't be it's very expensive
and you know what you make do you make
do ok so we have reached the end of the
week congratulations to you and
congratulations to me we are here that
means that we will be back on Monday
over the weekend try not to run things
more than they already have been ruined
I know I'm hoping in vain but what can I
do
we'll be back next week i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]